good morning home secretary thank you
for joining us before we turn to the
announcements that you want to make on
immigration
can we spend a moment on the revelations
about the bbc
lord dyson the duke of cambridge the
duke of sussex
and now many of the bbs young
journalists have called the national
broadcasters integrity
into question do you personally
trust the bbc well i think it's
important to recognize
the criticism and the deep concern
associated with the report that was
published by lord dayton
um the bbc itself one of our great
institutions its reputation has been
compromised it's being questioned right
now
and they themselves will have to reflect
upon the report and spend a great deal
of time
i think really looking at how they can
regain
and rebuild trust and confidence
confidence and trust of the british
public but also they are a world-class
institution
so they will have a great deal of work
to do in this particular area
and of course right now it's a very very
important time for the bbc to very much
look at itself and learn some very
important and significant lessons post
the publication of this report
but the word i'm not hearing in answer
to my question do you
personally trust the bbc is yes
can you say yes well absolutely at this
stage
we are focused and even from a personal
perspective i'm very conscious of
the hurt the damage that this report has
highlighted
and on that basis trevor you've already
heard me say i think the reputation of
the bbc has been compromised there's no
question about that
trust and confidence has been undermined
and now is the time for the bbc
to absolutely reflect upon the findings
of this report and rebuild that trust
and confidence
i'm hearing a note there and i'm
wondering if what that means is that
you think that the bbc cannot go on
marking its own
homework after jimmy savile after cliff
richard now after
this thing do you think
like for example lord grade that we need
some way new way of holding the
corporation to account for example he's
proposed
a new board of uh editorial policy
uh composed of experienced
independent journalists well i think um
there will be a review point um trevor
next year
is an opportunity when it comes to the
midterm review
of the bbc charter for government and
the bbc to absolutely look at
new ways of governance of the
institution the organization that is the
bbc
so my colleagues i know the culture
secretary in particular
will be working with the bbc to very
much use that moment as an opportunity
and i say this as an opportunity
to review governance and accountability
structures
and post this report that's going to be
a very very important moment
some of this does come into your
wheelhouse doesn't it the metropolitan
police
are saying that though they looked at
this in march
the dyson report has caused them to look
at the
situation again do you rule out the
possibility
of criminal prosecutions well trevor
it's not for me at this
early stage to even speculate and
comment on anything of that nature
clearly investigations if they are
taking place you know that has to go
through the process
but fundamentally right now i come back
to very much from a government
perspective there will be an opportunity
specifically on the governance of the
bbc
where there will be an opportunity not
only for reflection but an opportunity
to
look at governance reforms and how
effectively accountability and
governance can be strengthened
there will be a very very significant
moment now there's no question about
this
where lessons have to be learned yes
within the bbc
itself yes with the leadership of the
bbc it's
journalists and people that work for the
bbc too
but ultimately the governance and
accountability
that ultimately would lead to public
trust public confidence
in the way in which the bbc operates and
the way in which it conducts its
business
but you talk about this being an early
moment and i
understand that but what i take you to
be saying
to the metropolitan police and its boss
cressida dick
that if they find a reason
to proceed with any criminal
prosecutions there will be no pushback
from the home office if that is their
judgment well look i'm not trevor it's
not for me to even
contemplate or speculate um anything in
that i'm not asking you to speculate
absolutely
i'm simply asking you to confirm what
you've already said i think
well i think it's important right now to
reflect upon
findings of the report and any other
information that comes out that is
associated specifically
with what has happened and of course you
know if there is subsequent action that
needs to be taken then clearly
alongside the publication of this report
lessons being learned
and changes changes to the institution
structure governance accountability
then that will follow from a government
perspective i should just emphasize
again
obviously there'll be a midterm review
of the charter next year
and my colleagues in government will
absolutely ensure that that is used
as the right opportunity not just for
reflection but to enhance governance and
accountability within the bbc
okay the bbc's unnoticed let's just have
a quick word if i may
on the vaccine situation public health
england say this morning that the
vaccines we're using in britain are
effective against the indian variant
is that news that means that we can look
forward
to reopening on june the 21st well i
think trevor we should all
really um just look look at the success
of the vaccine
program and how that is gradually
enabling us all to
live our lives the reopening of society
unlocking of aspects of our economy
clearly that's
exactly what the road map is all about
and the prime minister himself is being
clear
that there are key tests and key stages
in the run-up to the 21st
of june we will always continue to look
at the data when it comes to the next
stage of the roadmap that is sensible
that is responsible and i think we
should absolutely just reflect upon the
success of the vaccine
and how that is giving people
individuals society businesses
confidence to be back out there again
what is a very critical time you know
a year after lockdown and very tough
decisions that have been made by the
government
so um maybe two cheers uh across the
nation for that let's uh turn to an area
for which you are
directly responsible and that is
immigration you and the prime minister
regularly remind us that we now have
control
of our own borders so why are you
planning to spend time and resource on
new legislation
well these are important changes trevor
around the uk's approach to immigration
and it is correct the prime minister
rightly
and i speak about this is absolutely
part of our manifesto commitment
to take back control of our borders and
we've done that
by ending free movement that was part of
leaving the eu
but also introducing a new points base a
british points based immigration system
that's one
important aspect of legal migration
dealing with legal migration and how we
have our rules in place
how we also support the brightest and
the best to come to the united kingdom
to
bolster our economy and support
businesses in terms of their own
economic growth
what i'm unveiling and proposing
tomorrow is a new legal migration and
borders strategy
which very much sets the framework for
the future which is based upon
digitalization of our borders
but also the simplification of our
immigration laws
currently thus far we've already
simplified something like 21 immigration
routes
and we're in the process of simplifying
almost 500 pages of immigration
legislation and rules and there is so
much more that we can do in this whole
error and that's effectively what i'll
be doing
tomorrow home secretary i understand why
you're focusing on simplification and
technology
and so on and so forth but in what way
will new electronic gates at airports
stop boats crossing the channel to kent
or people hiding in lorries well there
are two
so trevor there are two points to make
here first of all digitalization is
absolutely
important because we can upstream checks
we can do checks on individuals before
they even arrive in our country
and that's important in terms of quality
are not presenting themselves to be
checked
i will come on to that in a minute i'm
also when it comes to illegal migration
so the digitalization is speaking about
legal immigration
illegal migration is a very very
important problem
and issue for our country it has been an
issue for decades and decades whether
it's a back of lorries or people
crossing the channel
in very very dangerous circumstances
being facilitated by
criminal gangs and people smugglers i am
introducing the new borders bill which
will come to parliament
next month where we will specifically
clamp down and tackle
the problems around illegal migration we
are going to change our laws
we will have not just greater checks
we've already got very very significant
law enforcement
operations taking a place in france in
belgium
upstream and we're already prosecuting
and arresting the people
smugglers last wednesday i myself saw a
number of arrests of people that have
been trafficking and facilitating people
but the key the key point to make trevor
is that when it comes to claiming asylum
and we are going to change our asylum
laws
and our asylum system because it's
broken people that are being smuggled
they should be claiming asylum
in a safe country the first safe country
that they travel through
more often not these are eu member
states rather than taking the risk of
coming to the united kingdom
and so we are going to be proposing
legislation i've made the announcements
already
we've published our new plan for
immigration which tackles this very
issue illegal migration trafficking
okay home secretary let's get this in in
perspective
uh since the beginning of the year uh i
think that you
have deported uh something like 700
foreign criminals but according to the
pew research organization there are
something like 800
000 to a million undocumented migrants
in this
country and that i think is probably
what most people
are worried about how you deal with that
and the proposals you make don't
don't address that at all and let's take
a case in point ten days ago
in glasgow uh the borders
uh agency uh border force attempted to
remove two
indian men uh from pollock shields
because they'd overstayed
their visas a large crowd gathered
they blocked the road completely
peacefully by the way i should say
and in the end the border force gave up
and the men are still here
what are you going to do about that well
trevor you're exactly making the case as
to why we need to reform
our immigration reform has nothing to do
with this
it actually does so the reforms i'm
proposing
cover illegal legal migration and
illegal migration
so you mentioned for example the number
of people foreign national offenders
these are high harm criminals people
that have committed
all sorts of atrocities against british
citizens in the united kingdom
we will continue to remove those
individuals and in fact many of the part
of the proposals that i am bringing
forward
will make it easier for us to remove
foreign national offenders
so we will stream so if i may tell me
what you are going to do about the two
gentlemen
in pollock shoes i will in just a minute
so we will also be changing many of the
appeals processes where individuals
go to court again and again and again to
thwart
our ability as a government to remove
high harm individuals
or people that have overstayed their
right to be in the country or who have
come to the united kingdom
illegally so immigration enforcement and
not border force it's immigration
enforcement in glasgow
they were stopped from removing two
people that had no legal basis to be
in the united kingdom they were doing
their job the protesters
stopped that from happening in terms of
the removing those two individuals
there is a whole process around the
removal of people that should not be in
this country
um at all people that are here
to enable the government to remove
people with no legal basis to be here
offenders and criminals you're going to
have another go at re
removing these gentlemen
what do you think the first minister is
going to say
because in 10 days ago she tweeted
the home office needs to ask itself hard
questions after today
doing this on eid in the heart of our
muslim community and in the midst of a
serious covet outbreak
was staggeringly irresponsible but the
even deeper
problem is an appalling asylum
immigration policy are you going to
confront nicolas sturgeon on this
question
well the point about our immigration
policy immigration is a reserve matter
for the government here and quite
frankly it's pretty clear that when it
comes to
the nationalists in scotland they would
much rather have an immigration policy
of open borders
no checks when it comes to criminals
coming to the uk
and no border controls and i think
actually her comments
also reflect upon the nationalist
position when it comes to
removing people that have no legal basis
to be in the uk
this is nothing to do with with eid at
all
immigration enforcement absolutely doing
their job
doing their job in terms of removing
people with no legal basis to be in the
uk
i think it's absolutely sorry a sorry
state of affairs that we see the
nationalists in scotland
basically trying to thwart the safety
and security
of the british public but also trying to
prevent the british government from
removing those with no legal basis to be
in the
united kingdom this is trevor exactly
the reason why we are changing our laws
and bringing in new legislation so that
the government can remove
people that should not be in our country
while protecting the safety and security
of british citizens
through the legal routes and the
digitalization that i'm proposing
i look forward to returning to this with
you uh home secretary before we finish
can i briefly return to a topic that's
very much in your on your entry and that
is the windrush compensation scheme
where the home office has reported that
21 individuals have died before their
cases
could be processed you also
predicted that you should have paid out
at least 120
million pounds to victims of this
scandal by the end of march this year
in fact you've only paid out around 14
million pounds do you feel in any way
ashamed at the way your department has
treated these people
well i think first of all trevor when it
comes to the windrush scandal
and it was a scandal um there is a
very very significant report published
by wendy williams and
based on the lessons learned from that
scandal we're actually implementing the
recommendations from wendy and the
changes that were
that she put forward and that report
came out last march i've been clear
to my department that those reforms are
coming they're in place
but you specifically asked about the
compensation scheme now it is
what i asked about was how you felt did
you feel ashamed about
what has happened windrush scandal has
been an absolute stain
quite frankly on our country but also on
what has happened in the home office
i've been very public about that and
i will reiterate that and i'll restate
that but it doesn't mean that we ignore
what has happened
so there have been a whole range of
changes that have taken place
but you specifically asked about
compensation now first of all the
compensation scheme
was designed in consultation with
members of the windrush community and
the generation themselves members of
that generation
in december so just five months ago
because the scheme was simply
too slow and complicated in terms of
bringing forward
payments i overhauled the scheme so in
the last five months
we have seen over 26 million
26 million pounds of payments being put
out
but also at the same time in march less
than two months ago
we had our highest month where eight
million pounds of compensation was paid
out
now the changes to the scheme have been
brought in place in conjunction with the
windrush stakeholder advisory group and
i do actually want to thank
everybody because these are members of
the community that worked
with me and with my the department to
find faster ways
of streamlining payments and getting
money out but trevor there is a lot more
work to do here there really is
i've been very vocal about this and it's
right that we work
night and day to fix not just the
compensation and get the money out but
also
many of the problems that led to people
involved in the
sexual scandal i i get that home
secretary and i hope we will have
more opportunities to talk about this
again thank you very much for your time
this morning